a seven-year-old arrives home with her
first report card from school which is
full of terrible grades her dad leans
over her shoulder to take a peek at the
academic horror show
the girl turns around and asks so what
do you think dad nature or nurture
centuries ago john locke and others
began arguing that our personality is
mainly shaped by the environment we were
raised in
others such as charles darwin believe
that we are largely programmed
genetically
modern behavioral geneticists think that
it's more complex because the two
interact
and relatively recently a little
crayfish from germany showed just how
little we actually know
but more about her later
first let's go back to the girl her dad
and what we do know
neither the dad nor the smartest
scientists can answer what leads to
certain school outcomes of our
seven-year-old girl
we do know however a bit about the
influences of genes and the environment
when it comes to groups of specific
populations
take for example a group of a hundred
white american men in their early
twenties and you will probably find on
average an iq of a hundred a height of a
hundred and seventy eight centimeters or
around five point eight feet and the ten
have spelling problems
we can now ask which of these three
traits is determined by genes anything
that happened before conception often
referred to as nature
and which by the environment anything
that happened after their mothers got
pregnant often referred to as nurture
to understand the two forces we need to
acknowledge that environmental
influences are often random siblings
experience home very differently
and we need to recognize that genes are
complex there is no single gene doing a
single thing
we therefore know little about which
trait in an individual is the result of
their genetic makeup and which is due to
the environment we only know about the
impact of nature and nurture on trait
differences of a particular group and to
learn about that we need to understand
heritability
heritability is a factor that ranges
between one and zero one stands for
genetic influences
zero for environmental factors
heritability defines the genetic impact
on trait differences in a particular
population it cannot measure the degree
to which a trait of a particular
individual is genetic
dyslexia for example has a heritability
closer to one that means that genes
explain more of the difference in
spelling mistakes of our group than
school family or random factors
it does not mean that one particular
person with spelling problems got them
genetically some just didn't get much
support when they were young
how complex the interaction between
genes and environment really is becomes
clear when we look at something as
seemingly straightforward as iq and
height
first let's examine height
a group of a hundred white american male
students are on average 178 centimeters
tall that's roughly 5 feet 10 inches
their heritability for height is around
0.8
if some men in this group are 183
centimeters or 6 feet tall then
heritability allows us to assume that 80
percent of that difference is on average
caused by genetic variance and 20
percent of the difference is due to
lifestyle
if the same group of people were raised
in a region that experienced systemic
droughts and they never had enough to
eat their potential for an average
height of 178 centimeters is far from
ever being reached
the heritability for height might now go
from 0.8 down to 0.5
nature and nurture are now equally
responsible for group differences
this means heritability changes
if we have a well-nourished population
on the one side and a malnourished group
on the other then the impact of
nutrition on the differences in height
changes from 20 percent to 50 percent in
other words
nurture matters a lot until we reach a
point from which it's not as relevant
so what about intelligence
the heritability of iq is around 0.6 for
people in their 20s and then increases
as we age
the average iq in our group will be
around 100 but some have an iq of 110.
genes are therefore responsible for
sixty percent of the difference and
random factors in the environment for
about forty percent in other words for
those with an iq of a hundred and ten
six of the additional ten points can on
average be attributed to nature and four
points to nurture
now even if nurture plays a big role it
doesn't mean that teachers or parents
had any impact
unlike height which we know how to
increase through nutrition when it comes
to iq we don't know much about how to
improve it
random factors seem to play a big role
how random the environment is becomes
clear when we look at two kids that are
born into the same family
both are raised in the same shared
environment but firstborns on average
turn out to be more intelligent than
their younger siblings and if one of the
two siblings was adopted the two would
have some correlation in iq during their
upbringing but as adults they would be
hardly more similar in intelligence than
complete strangers
parents it seems have a very limited
impact on a child's iq
[Music]
so now what about that crayfish
in 1995 german scientists made an odd
observation the little female creature
had mutated and become asexual able to
make clones of itself
as each clone shared exactly the same
genetic blueprint the scientists set up
an experiment for the ultimate test
hundreds of these little identical
creatures were placed in the same
environment same water same temperature
same amount of food
even though the scientists tried to
control all these variables the
unthinkable happened
some crayfish stayed tiny others grew
big
some died others lived on and on and
while some became social others enjoyed
solitude
why do you think that happened is that
nature nurture or a complex interplay of
the two with some random variations in
replicated genetic code
to download this video without
background music and to learn more about
the topic visit sproutschools.com
[Music]
this and all other sprouts videos are
licensed under creative commons that
means teachers from all around the world
can use them in classrooms online
courses or to start projects and today
thousands already do
to learn how it works and download this
video without ads or background music
check out our website or read the
description below
if you want to support our mission and
help change education visit our patreon
that's patreon.com
sprouts
you